hier das muss vorher alles da sein damit
ich so ein Windrad aufstellen darf das
hier ist die To-Do-Liste des Landes
Baden-Württemberg da stehen dann so
Sachen drauf wie hier mein best of
Angaben zur Auswirkung auf das
Erscheinungsbild von Kulturdenkmalen
oder hier Antrag auf Waldumwandlung
bezogen auf den anlagenstandort oder
hier auch ein Liebling von mir
Schattenwurf Prognose oder hier äh
Angaben zur optisch bedrängenden Wirkung
was für mich nach bodyshaming für
Windräder klingt Angaben zur optisch
Bedrängung und Wirkung oh das Ding da
das so nah da müssen wir erstmal gucken
ob ich das bedrängt
wisst ihr wie Leute aus der Stadt das
nennen wenn man etwas unschönes vor der
Nase hat statt